what you need to know this morning
begins with
running back news galore and we're going
to start with alvin
kamara there is
chris and you're hearing it i'm hearing
it i'm reading it
i'm seeing it i'm hearing from different
people that i know
all of a sudden right there was nothing
about alvin khmer all of a sudden it's
crazy
like it's everywhere like and and it's a
ping-pong of different rumors and
reports and
they're they're willing to trade him
well actually a couple of nights ago
they started making
calls in an effort to shop him
and i believe it has nothing to do with
trying to trade him and everything to do
with demonstrating to camara that no one
else is going to pay him
what the saints are willing to pay him
because a new team would also have to
give up enough to placate the saints to
make the trade happen so a trade
is not going to happen the market just
isn't where alvin kamara
wants it to be the saints i think are
moving toward getting a deal done kamara
is moving toward compromising
here's the problem once christian
mccaffrey got 16 million a year
that's right that set everything into a
tizzy for alvin kamara because the
saints have long believed that kamara is
every bit as good as mccaffrey well
if mccaffrey gets 16 you got a problem
if you think your guy is as good
as christian mccaffrey the problem is
they don't use him the way the panthers
use mccaffrey so at some point
somebody's got to convince camara
you're not going to burn bright for a
short period of time like mccaffrey
you're going to be around longer you're
going to make more maybe over the course
of your career than mccaffrey
because we're not over using you and so
it's better to accept a lesser amount
because you're going to play longer at a
lesser amount you're going to be used
less
than a guy who is used to justify yeah
top of the market money right and i
think that's that's how they're trying
to work this through to get camaro to
understand why
he's not at or close to the christian
mccaffrey level
financially yeah well i i hope he he
does understand that i mean
that that's what i had always kind of
heard through the process is that's
where the
asking number the negotiation started
was the christian mccaffrey number
no you know that's not going to happen
first off you know alvin kamara is an
awesome player camaro is an awesome
player we know that
is he christian mccaffrey absolutely not
and also
you know is he as vital to the success
of the new orleans saints as christian
mccaffrey is no
absolutely not you know the saints as
great as alvin kamara is
hey sean payton you know he can get a
lot of people open there's michael
thomas there there's of course drew
brees
jared cook there's the other supporting
system you know most base level fans
when you just go carolina panthers they
just go oh christian mccaffrey
i mean yeah teddy bridgewater but he's
not like a major
he's in a proven part of his career
right now dj moore
receiver so the whole team is based
around christian mccaffrey that's
different than what
alvin kamara is asked to do there with
new orleans even though he's a very
important part
now yeah mccaffrey blows it out of the
water mccaffrey is doing special things
i think he's clearly the best running
back in football you know now you start
to look at it okay who are the other
guys in that conversation
and to me i don't think it's
coincidental
that this came out on a day where we saw
joe mixon get a new
contract either i would think that threw
a little bit of a
a wrench into things or whether alvin
kamara
liked joe mixon's contract or thinks he
deserves to be
paid significantly more i don't know
but what i would argue is if he's
getting anything north of joe mixon i
would say take it alvin kamara
take it that's just the way it is the
market is is weird right now
derek henry for the tennessee titans
signed for less money
than cj2k did what was that nine years
ago at running back as far as year to
year goes so
yep the running back market is in a
weird spot right now
and i hope you know alvin kamara doesn't
box himself into a corner here where
you know he puts himself in the doghouse
in new orleans a little
and and the way that this all exploded
in the last 24 hours with
and it started i think it was schefter
who said there were unexcused absences
and camaro was going to be fined for it
i've heard that's disputed i've heard
he's been fined two hundred thousand
dollars i think there are reports to
that effect
there's even scuttlebutt that he and
sean payton the head coach got into it
not physically not late uh style from
years ago but
arguing they had some sort of an
argument and i don't know what's true
and what's not true i'm just telling you
what people are talking about
but it all came out of nowhere it's
amazing but
now the way that the dust settled by the
end of the day and maybe this is
something that just had to happen
by the end of the day back at the table
working on a deal with the goal of
getting the deal done
by monday and there's a degree of
confidence from people in the know
that despite all of this stuff despite
all the stuff that went on
they're going to get something done by
monday and i think you're right chris
joe mixon gets 12 million a year that's
the floor
for alvin kamara but but where's the
ceiling yeah the ceiling's mccaffrey
he's not getting a mccaffrey
he wants more than mixing and if
mccaffrey's at 16
and mixon's at 12 isn't this easy just
give him 14.
give him 13. 13.5 something put some
incentives in there
that would get him north of 14 based
upon
playing time based upon performance
there's a way to
massage this to make it life-changing
money for alvin kamara and also
to reflect the way the team feels about
him but also to
reflect the extent to which the team
uses him because they
don't use him the way that mccaffrey is
used and that's a benefit long term to
alvin kamara's career yeah well
you know i think you know what you said
is correct to me that's the way i kind
of see it
anything north of joe mixon i i think
should be good for albuquerque listen
let's be totally honest who would you
rather have it running back joe mixon or
alvin kamara
well i i i alvin kamara but i would use
him
like joe mixon it's different i know
well yeah i you know i
i would probably sit here and tell you i
think joe nixon's a probably more
talented running back and
more of a they're kind of a different
animal altogether
joe mixon's a bigger guy a beast i mean
he is thick and powerful looking alvin
kamara you and i have seen him before
yeah he's got some muscle but he's more
of the variety of like
you know that third down in between type
running back if that
i hope i'm explaining that the correct
you said but you you said yesterday he's
their best between the tackles runner
and they have latavius murray
he is he there's no doubt i'm not trying
to downplay the importance of alvin
kamara and how good of a damn player he
is i'm truly not
i'm just trying to flush out this
conversation as far as you know the
money
and where he stands in this and i think
that that's what i'm getting down to i
think you just got to be happy to
anything above joe mixon
and i think the saints they probably
realize like hey to save face alvin
kamara the things he's done for our team
we've gone to the playoffs we gotta pay
him a little more
than joe mixon what what's and then of
course derek henry at 12-5
the ones that are confusing the
conversation i would expect too
is that david johnson and le'veon bell
contract you know that's where i'm sure
alvin camaro is looking at that going
wait but they're north of 13 million
dollars a year
and i'm better than them and that is for
damn sure he's better from that better
than they are
um but yeah david johnson and and
le'veon bell were fortunate to get two
teams that were kind of stupid and
giving him a contract that was a little
too expensive
and this is the key with running backs
and this is what i tell people
agents people from teams and yes some of
them do talk to me from time to time
basically because they need some
janitorial work done but
the uh the the reality is
running backs get paid for what they've
done
yes not for what they're going to do
right that's the danger yeah le'veon
bell
isn't worth 13 and a half million per
year right now
but he was at some point exactly right
david johnson isn't worth 13 million per
year now
but he was at some point and that's what
teams are trying to avoid and that's why
like a dalvin cook right
right why won't the vikings make him a
huge offer because the vikings see
the le'veon bell contract they see the
david johnson contract they see the todd
gurley contract
how many of these long-term big money
running back contracts are done by the
team
and a year later they wish they had
never done it
right they regret it already right and
you get boxed into a corner and
you know that's why derek henry did the
deal that he did to stay
in tennessee you only get big money from
the team that drafted you and the team
that saw you become a star because that
fan base
demands that the guys stay with the team
right and you're signing the guy to
placate your fan base it's a customer
service move
that's what it is and that started with
sean alexander it continued with
ladainian tomlinson
and and that's when about that same time
frame now tomlinson continued to earn it
but that's that same time frame where
you see sean payton go to new orleans
he's got reggie bush but that's fine
i've got deuce mcallister i've got
pierre thomas right i'm gonna start
rotating these guys
so there's no one guy that i get backed
into a corner and have to pay huge money
to and now
after all these years sean payton is on
the brink of having to pay more than he
wants to pay
to a running back yeah no he is he's a
and well you know that's
why we see teams do running back
committee to your point and that's why
you're right new orleans look at look at
the new england patriots
hey james white he's really good do i
think he's a superstar
no but they know hey we're creative
we're smart you know wolf
this guy's smart too and he's got some
skills of course
that will make it look better than maybe
he really is because we'll game plan and
design and do things that way too
uh so you're right that's to me the the
more popular way of
addressing the running back position in
the modern day nfl because
uh we know how brutal brutal position is
it is a short shelf life
uh the one thing i'll say you know that
i'm
i'm happy to see is the owners are are
stepping up a little bit as far as the
running back position
and not like holding their feet to the
fire until it's year five or year six to
where it's like
okay this guy yeah give him some money
even though he's like
he's his body's beat to death and it's
coming to an end as far as his career
i do like the recent trend of what we
saw with ezekiel elliott and giving
jerry jones a lot of credit for that
you know and these these deals being
done after this he had to go to mexico
for a month to hold he had to hit i know
to draw a line in the sand and disappear
to get his money they didn't do it out
of the goodness of their heart
well either way he took care of them and
at least they're entertaining it more
as what i'm saying in year three than
anything before we used to not see that
and that used to bother me and i do
think that's changed just a little bit
remember what we said though last year
before ezekiel
held out we said now is the time to make
your stand because the offense could
change this year
the pendulum could swing toward the
passing game and what happened last year
yeah with the dallas offense so what's
going to happen this year
with mike mccarthy there right so the
the thing is
you know you've and and i think that's
the fair way to do it
because it's not appropriate it's not
right
for a team to be able to take a running
back especially in round one
where you have the fifth year option you
can keep the guy for
every game of that first contract
through five seasons
you can franchise tag him for a year and
then you just walk away you got your six
years out of him he's a running back
he's used up by that point no we're not
paying you
and the market's not going to pay you
that's exactly what happened to melvin
gordon with the chargers
exactly with the exception of the
franchise tag they chewed him up
on a five-year deal they didn't want to
pay him he held out last year
and the chargers said we're not why
we're not doing this
we'll keep austin eckler we'll pay him a
hell of a lot less money i mean that's
the thing folks
and again they don't like to peel that
curtain back they don't like you to see
the man behind the curtain they don't
want you to understand that at the core
it's a business football is business and
there's no position
where the business realities are more
important than running back because most
of these big contracts
are lifetime achievement awards and now
we're seeing
guys taking a stand after three seasons
when the window opens on a contract
that's when they say pay me and
that's what khmer is doing that's what
mixon did remember last week he was
missing practice with migraines yeah it
turns out they were
migraines mixing held in mixon got paid
camara apparently holding in he's gonna
get paid
and that that's that's how you do it
because if you wait too long
what's going to happen you're going to
have a year or two under that new
contract they're going to tear it up and
throw it away because by then you're not
earning it
yeah no you're exactly right i mean
that's why these guys got
these running backs got to draw a line
in the sand to what you said to
make these things happen and i got total
respect for alvin kamara and what he's
doing here
yeah he's got to take care of himself
his body he's been banged up already we
know that
and you know as we talked about
yesterday he does have leverage from the
sense of
he is you know again not christian
mccaffrey to his offense
but really important to his offense and
not just that because he's a talented
player
but there's a true scheme need
for that type of player there and i know
they got ty montgomery behind him and
i'm sure he'll be pretty good at doing
some of that stuff too
but he ain't alvin kamara and uh yeah
sean payton's he's stuck with this one
you know he got a guy that he really
liked
he fed him the ball stats say it fantasy
world loves him
team wins fan base gets behind it just
like you talked about and now they go
wait
we can't win without him he needs to be
a mainstay and the team gets boxed him
in a corner and has to pay
him and you know uh i got no problem
with that the big thing is to me mike
where
where do you think what's that what do
you think the money he'll finally settle
on i mean
realistically is he going to be happy if
he gets 12-5 like just derek henry
or he'll be happy in between derrick
henry and a joe mixon or does he want
more than that
and this goes on for a little bit longer
i have a feeling that it's going to be
closer to mixon and henry than mccaffrey
but there may
be some terms in there that
that will at first blush create the
impression that it's a better deal than
it is
right gotcha that the ego creeps into it
and we see
some fluff that gets built into deals
whether it's for the agent's benefit
when it comes to using that deal to
recruit new clients
or whether it's the player who just
wants to be able to say
i got paid like so and so even when you
scratch the surface and you realize
he didn't really get paid like that guy
but it's part of that process of saying
i got paid like that guy hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports